what's one of two lines back Econoline
and we have an added bonus right now hi
one sirs that are watching right now
thank you so much for tuning in right
now and I am so excited that you are all
over here we are gearing up for another
magical season and I know that we're
going to a whole new world right now
with the introduction of Aladdin ah ah
you got me you got me uh how are you
guys feeling about this new world that
we are going to be introducing it's very
exciting exciting um I'm excited about
the magic carpet ride I want to race it
with my broomstick I'm totes gonna win
see we did careful it's waiting Megan oh
yeah yeah right chance with the pole
right well I was gonna say well who is
this we haven't really had the town
sheriff really back in action I was
gonna say who would be writing those
speeding tickets are we gonna be having
a little bit more of that normal
day-to-day Storybrooke life this year
normal Storybrooke is horrible
yeah I don't think so I'm so weird
though I would love like one just like
wonderfully normal day we see like like
we can see like you know the whole
family get together Granny's have dinner
just like chat around a table I can
thanks Lane episode 2 minutes ago
happiness I think they'd be great just
to hold us over well considering we left
last year in absolute tears right now so
many things happen Lana Hari
cuz I'm not okay that's my kind of split
in two right yeah she's gonna flip to
shake down hashtags alone but no but so
how how are we gonna be seeing Regina
move forward with the loss of Robyn and
how are you doing without Shaun oh we
miss Shan Shan part of the families we
all miss Shan is one of the funniest
people I've ever known I think everyone
would agree yeah um I think her Jana's
having she's struggling she's having a
difficult time with it but Virginia is
also very private so I think her morning
takes place behind closed doors like
she's not very public with that but
she's some obviously grieving but
there's a lot going on in Storybrooke so
if you have to go straight into action
is it you you said she's typically very
private but she really did open up about
the struggles that she has been facing
with her good birth evil on the inside
and now that we see that she has been
split in two and that that evil side is
still around how has that been for you
playing those two different dynamics
it's been a journey it's it's it's um
it's still being discovered it's been
fun are you getting paid twice as much I
better not be it's it's been fun it's
just early on it's second episode and
last week we just shot the scene where
the Evil Queen you know confronts Regina
so that's about all I could say um but
and that was fun to play it was
different
like I said it comes with its challenges
but I
we're gonna continue to learn how to go
about all of it as we move forward and
I'm curious to see how the sisterly
dynamic is going to be evolving this
year now that we do have baby Robin yeah
yes it's a full-time job it's exhausting
if but you're such a great mom
oh thank you I'm trying cuz you know I
don't know anything about having a
babies Elena's pretty useless to be fair
sometimes I'm holding alike this is just
totally awkward but it's fun my sister's
helping me so we are gonna see them kind
of evolve and get stronger together cuz
I love it when they are on the same team
well I don't know about that ah I think
you're gonna be surprised about where
we're headed and now just you know I
have answering all these questions that
comic-con reveals am i oh my god I've
got two sisters like it's really sinking
in I'm like this is a lot of work so
I've got to Regina's double-die salon
yeah well and and while you have your
baby
Belle is pregnant and trapped in a box
um how you doing right good why well
because no it's just like I get that
it's like a normal predicament in
Storybrooke but typically it's like not
something you hear about every day
eventually uh yeah no she it's getting
cramped in there and rent I mean it up
Belle does extract herself or is
extracted and she dies so can we expect
some good run Belle scenes we have some
great scenes and yeah lots revealed
about Sur past present and future and
the decisions surrounding things that
she
you know it's it's a lot different
obviously dealing with what you're going
to do with a child involved when and
just what you're going to do as a single
adult so it's obviously changing her
path a little bit I love that and what I
also loved was the fact that Henry has a
love interest fully we got a kiss
he's the mom said finally hey hey what
what's grandpa Sharman thinking about
this I think it's a good yeah I think
it's a great thing I think so yeah she
uses yes I'm on the engine side are you
just saying that cuz you might live
hurry out yeah yes but no I am really
excited to see the dynamics this year
obviously we do not have the dark one
like we did last year when we were
coming into comic-con but what are we
gonna see from the Savior this year um
Emma's been through a lot in the last
six years so she's kind of introspective
I think she's realizing that some of the
things that she's been battling and
dealing with him built up and she's
never faced them because it's like one
crisis to the next so as we're facing
all the new crises she's actually
realizing that there's a lot to be faced
internally so she's she's definitely
not at her strongest at this point and
you know I need to know the best captain
Swann tees you can give me what's next
for this duo right here because he kind
of came back from the dead so I feel
like you really need to live life to the
fullest now well yeah guess so and I
mean it's it's different sort of now
because actually we know that it's you
know towards the end the last season
that it's true love and so obviously
things all right what I mean like that's
that's what I was part of the storyline
so yeah but yeah I guess they're sort of
it's gonna be how they can develop and
sort of progress and flourish their
relationship in you know stir this
Storybrooke ladies now and also like
within the commitment of true love you
know I think there's something different
about two people who know they want to
be together and they decided to be
together and then you do still face
obstacles and you do still face ups and
downs and so but those two ups and downs
aren't necessarily threatening the
relationship they're just things that
they have to work through together and
so we're kind of looking at some of the
nuances of that and you know as
relationship develops all the things
that naturally come with that so what
are those things mean and when are those
things coming he's also a 300 year old
pirate who's gonna love you look great
friends parents discovered that they had
a true love relationship they got
married so
so gonna put a ring on it this year that
man just would you give him a second
he's only just come back from the day so
and Josh talked me about the Charming's
real quick what do you want to know I
want to know when they're gonna get back
into the action I know that you were
back in the action evil queen is back
what does that mean yeah the whole basis
of Once Upon a Time started with the
Evil Queen trying to kill snow so she's
gonna be full-fledged people coming
after snow which means that she's coming
after charming so they're gonna have a
lot to deal with there but Regina isn't
Regina's not so that's the that's the
problem we all have to deal with well I
got you dead we @eg you don't care if
you are heroes or villains but we do
want to turning into action figures so
we have a super cool photobooth if you
guys want to come over here you guys can
all get into it together and pretend
like you are stuck in an action figure
box and you can all fit